there's no better time than now to be a
gamer and that's simply because we have
a lot of options of what we play
and how we play it but with options
comes the need to make decisions and to
make decisions
you need to be as informed as possible
on questions like
what is the playstation plus collection
or psnow
is it like game pass are they the same
and what service is right for my
gaming needs well buckle up buckaroo
because i'm about to clear all that up
for you
we're going to go through what each
service is what they cost and exactly
what it is
they offer there will also be timestamps
below if you're looking to clear up
anything specific
alright let's get on with it let's start
with playstation plus
ps plus allows you to play games online
with friends as well as get a couple
free games a month
and sometimes nav exclusive discounts
and deals in the playstation store
and if you get a playstation 5 it gives
you access to the playstation plus
collection
the playstation plus collection is 18
ps4 games that
sony considers quote generation defining
this curated collection will be
available to play at ps5's launch for
playstation plus subscribers
then we have ps now it's a game
streaming service that allows you to
stream over 700 ps2 ps3
and ps4 games through your ps4 ps5
or windows pc of the 700
games 400 of them are also available to
download directly to your console as
well
similar to a netflix-like model new
games are being occasionally added
while others leave it's an ever-changing
selection of games
xbox game pass is a library of over a
hundred games
old and new available to xbox and pc
users through
a monthly subscription and just like ps
now the list is
always changing with games coming and
going with the exception
of first party xbox games like halo and
gears
those are locked in unlike ps now
however
this is not a streaming service instead
the games are downloadable directly to
your console same with the playstation
plus collection
game pass ultimate allows streaming of
its library on android devices but
we'll get into that in a moment next the
cost
and perks ps plus is 59.99 per year or
you can try it for 9.99 a month
or 24.99 for three months as for the
playstation plus collection
keep in mind it's exclusive to ps5 and
your subscription needs to be active to
take advantage
of the goods however the ps5 is
backwards compatible
ps now has the same pricing model as ps
plus
it's 59.99 per year or if you want to
try for a month you can give it a shot
for 9.99
also a nice perk is that the online
multiplayer games in the ps now library
do not require you to have a ps plus
membership
to play them alright game pass this is
where things get
a little more convoluted but i promise
i'll make sense of it for you
so game pass has a couple tiers first we
have the base 999 monthly subscription
with it you get access to its 100 plus
games library on your console
including and this is a big one day one
access to games developed by xbox game
studios
like ninja theory 343 industries and
bethesda
as well as exclusive member discounts
and deals that means games like
hellblade 2
halo infinite and upcoming bethesda
titles like starfield will be playable
day one at no extra cost on game pass
then there's game pass for pc which is
4.99 a month
which offers a different library of pc
only games
lastly there's game pass ultimate which
is 14.99 a month
this tier allows you to play on console
and pc
and include some extra free in-game
perks access to ea play which is another
collection of ea published games all its
own
access to streaming the game pass
library on mobile devices with the
possibility of other devices to come
and xbox live gold okay so
hold on in case you don't know xbox live
gold like playstation plus
enables online multiplayer gaming gives
you a couple free games a month
and some exclusive deals xbox live gold
on its own
however is 59.99 a year but does not
include game pass does that mean you're
actually saving anything
through having game pass ultimate as
opposed to just having a
game pass normal subscription and the
xbox live gold
separately let's do some quick math xbox
live gold
59.99 a year plus game pass normal
999 a month which equates to 119.88
a year equals 179.87
game pass ultimate just at 14.99 a month
equals 179.88
so for penny more you're getting access
to streaming xbox games on other devices
ea play and game pass for pc also
something to consider if you're choosing
between game pass normal and ultimate
is that unlike xbox live gold you can
cancel your game pass subscription
anytime
so if you get xbox live gold for the
year know that there ain't no coming
back it's 60 bucks
and that's it oh and one more thing
unlike the playstation plus collection
all of game passes console library is
currently available
on the previous generation of xbox one
consoles
as well as the xbox series x and
s okay so what about having both
playstation plus and playstation now
having both services will put you at 120
a year
that's 60 dollars cheaper than game pass
ultimate
just keep in mind that playstation now
does not get day 1 releases of first
party playstation games
so you'll be shelling out 70 dollars for
games like demon souls
on top of having both services okay
you still with me finally the games
we're going to start with game pass this
time there's a lot
too much to list in this video some old
games from the og xbox some from the 360
and plenty of new ones it's a wide
variety of genres and styles both
aaa and indie and game pass gives you
the chance to play something you may not
have otherwise considered giving a shot
maybe it's because you didn't want to
spend 60 to take a risk on final fantasy
xv
or you've never even heard of night in
the woods it's a low risk opportunity to
try something new oh and uh play
hellblade there's also cases of non-xbox
game studios
getting day one releases as well like
spirit fair and carrion
it's just more of a case-by-case
scenario i don't think i would have ever
played a farming simulator
if it wasn't for game pass but now i too
understand the solace and peace that
comes
with being a virtual farmer or maybe you
miss the 360 generation
well now's the time to play alan wake
just know it's an evolving selection
with new games on the way
but of course at the cost of a monthly
subscription
some of game pass's heaviest hitters of
the moment are doom eternal
destiny 2 and its expansions gears 5
halo master chief collection forza and
the outer world
just to name a few of the hundred plus
others
similarly ps now with 700 games on it
offers the same chance to try an
overwhelming amount of games there's a
number of caveats here to keep in mind
however
first the library while enormous is
primarily older games
even the more recent ones on there are a
couple years old like days gone
dishonored 2
and metal gear solid 5. second even if
you have a remarkable internet
connection
streaming games is still not the most
finely tuned experience
currently for ps now the resolution for
streaming is kept at 720p
not to mention input lag third
thankfully
400 of the games are downloadable and
can easily be categorized in the search
menu to make it easier
but certain flagship first party games
like the first last of us or
even fallout new vegas aren't while
there are some bangers in there to
download a large majority are ps2 games
or small scale indie games which is
totally fine just
just want to make sure you're aware of
it now let's take a look at the
playstation plus collection which
is a lot more straightforward with it
you're getting 18 games batman arkham
knight battlefield 1
bloodborne play bloodborne days gone
detroit become human
fallout 4 final fantasy 15 god of war
infamous second son the last guardian
the last of us remastered
monster hunter world mortal kombat 10
persona 5
brash and clank resident evil 7
biohazard uncharted 4
a thief's end and until dawn and also
really quick just something to note five
of these are also currently available
on game pass batman arkham knight final
fantasy 15 royal edition
monster hunter world mortal kombat 10
and resident evil 7.
however keep in mind that they may not
stick around on game pass forever
so that should just about cover it
explaining what playstation plus is
its collection and what you're paying
for is far easier to comprehend than
explaining game pass or ps now
but here's where the key differences lie
ps plus collection is a perk for ps5
owners
with a ps plus membership while game
pass is an ongoing and evolving service
across
xbox consoles and pc nps now is a
streaming downloadable service that
caters to a slightly older library
the most important takeaway is
understanding the value you're looking
for
in your gaming experience to put it into
dollars for game pass you're paying 180
a year to play day one releases like
halo infinite
psychonauts 2 the medium as well as
bethesda and obsidian games
games that otherwise could cost upwards
to seventy dollars a pop
so say you buy three full price games at
seventy dollars that puts you at two
hundred and ten dollars which
is thirty dollars more than what you'd
be paying for a year of game pass alone
and if you're a teenager like i once was
i had to flip my games in order to
afford playing something new
so for somebody like that and for me as
a teenager game pass
would have been a dream come true for
ps5 playstation plus members you get a
roster of 18 amazing games games that
probably aren't going anywhere for a
good while
and they'll be there when you're ready
to play them or just revisit them for
the 85th time because you want to see
how your little honey vicar emilia is
doing
now as of this recording we don't know
if sony plans to add more to the
playstation plus collection
so this may be it and even there it's
still great just a different value
proposition from what
xbox game pass offers and lastly if
you're not concerned about staying up to
date with every new big release
and are looking to catch up on titles
from yesteryear and beyond ps now offers
a lot for just 60 dollars a year
so whether you're buying a new ps5 or
xbox or just
trying to understand all of this i
really hope this was helpful for you
for more on the past present and future
of gaming keep your eyes on gamespot and
while you're at it check out generation
next it's the show
about next generation consoles alright
this was kurt
happy gaming and be well
[Music]
you